G my name Scar Face I
mean welcome back to um what the hell is
this room what the H Cry of Fear um I
figured out you have to um hold the hand
in ah [__] [__] R mom back off back
off back off back off what is that a
door in your face no doors are not
supposed to be in your face ah God damn
it m his mom when will she learn I will
Leone learn should we go in here or no I
think it's here we need to go to the
basement holy [__]
Senoritas oh God I don't like this okay
so do what we like a
b let's go down to the basement I don't
have much ammo I hear
water that is water lovely I hope you Ro
don't dude what the hell what are you
doing ah back off I will shoot you again
oh twice twice
quad oh he's lucky I didn't quad that
[__] oh snappy SN okay back to the
bement I hope you don't think this is
how this is Sweden by the way this game
takes place in Sweden but uh you know um
this is not actually how I can't open it
God damn
it all right so maybe we can increase
the pipes and we can swim up there or
something I don't even [__] know
where did I come from let's go in
here all right hey more water okay I'm
not I hope there's no water monster
hello is anyone in here say Lo on this
door okay when I do not
[Applause]
what stab me stab stab Reuben's M come
on come on come
on can't see anything just stab me like
a boss anyway ah
R okay I guess I have the cell phone in
my pocket or something why the hell did
my ammo go
where's ammo when you need it I don't
have any well that's fan [__] tastic
isn't it all right let's do a wheel not
these two these two stabby stab where
the hell am I why I don't even know how
I ran okay maybe in here shoes lovely
absolutely
fantastic Mr Shar I need drugs all right
py I'm your dealer but I don't have I'm
out of stash right now I don't care you
need I it won't budge neither of them
will budge let's go we should L him L
you there ah he never invites people to
this house L hey all right what is this
so let's go here I
guess Ruben's mom is a crazy [__] I got
to tell him that not not only in I have
one more Serene I haven't saved in like
forever so if I die now it's going to be
a [__] problem
all right we can't go there God damn
it okay why almost
free all right we're almost at the
basement this is the basement thanks
sweet Lord heaven of
Almighty let's say there God damn I
would have been so [__] if we can't um
all right which
door all right it's this one where's the
keys have already used them
what I I swear to God I had keys did I
drop them somewhere turn out I was right
I did drop them somehow if you just
click them once it I don't know whatever
I have the keys that's the point thank
Jesus no nothing all right I have how
many bullets bring it
[__] anyone want to [__] with me you
[__] with's mom no you don't actually
you do if you want to hey garbage bags
how you doing doing lovely good to see
you today how's the weather outside all
right what the hell what the hell is
that what resisting I'm resisting I'm
resisting back off [__] ah back off by
the power of s B's phone Sony ericon by
the power of what the hell is wrong with
you what the
hell stabby stab
chanes that is
disgusting oh my God what the [__] is
this is the most disturbing [__] I ever
[__] seen are you
kidding die
[__] oh my
God
holy really the [__]
baby oh my
god
oh oh you
oh like like if R's mom wasn't bad
enough I stab you [__] and I stab your
baby
too why does your baby have a knife
holy night night oh no I died no no no
[__] me [__] stabbing
babies Snappy SN everywhere that's just
all I got to say okay let's go inside
again and let's F how see that's how you
drop the keys if you clicking in the
wrong
order
okay buddy okay buddy let's just kill
some [__] baby more fish and
stuff okay bring
it okay it's okay it's okay everyone is
friendly here no one wants to fight okay
maybe a
little uh okay one two there we go it's
time for stabbing time it's time for
stabbing time really okay
whatever okay okay let's fight these
[__] let come on Tango you want a
Tango [__] you and your baby [__] you
and your baby [__] you and your baby
[__] you and your baby [__] you and your
baby [__] you and your baby all right
back
up [__] your baby's fast
ah ow okay oh snapy new I need drugs
don't look kids don't look at this it's
bad for you don't do it don't do
drags oh yeah it feels good oh yeah full
health [__] what you got about say
about that I have nothing to say about
that cuz whatever let's go here some
ammo would be [__] Splendid right now
or anything to be honest
hello okay let's go in here I
guess God damn what is
this is that what puzzle yeah this is
puzzle area for still on my dle hey
videotape I love
videotape
videotape hey drugs I love drugs more
than videotape okay Mr Shar what are you
doing I'm sorry py I kill her what what
you did what you're a murderer I didn't
mean to do it actually I don't care if
you don't care what what is this what do
I do here oh maybe it's not a pule after
all I got a video tape hope it's not a
bre Spirit back off I hate you and I
slap you back off
yes back and Dodge stab and Dodge like a
boss okay what is thank heavens thank
heavens all right let's put you there
buddy put you there
buddy and
reload okay so I guess I keep the gun in
my pocket cuz I it won't budge well
that's Splendid my mouse is being all
ape [__] and
stuff uh two so where the [__] do I go
here
maybe why did this place I don't like
this what I came from here I shot the
[__] we go in here
lovely no I came from
there okay let's see here here it must
be unlocked oh I unlocked the dock
unlock the dock really that's
awesome all right let's save here like a
boss and now where did I come
from [__] Mouse you keep [__] me
over can't stop Mouse I know we have
other
differences where am
I [__] mouth come on not mouth I'm
sorry let's
go
here I guess seriously you don't buy
Mouse wait I already been
here but what's the point I got a
videotape so I'm supposed to go where I
need a video player to play it I don't
remember where there was some video tape
do you bro
remember I don't
remember [__] this is a
problem
wait wait let's see here I'm trying to
think it's difficult when I have no
brain oh oh Furniture scared me that's
just fantastic
okay so well maybe it is
here did I come from
here did I I didn't check all the
doors there was this crazy baby [__]
over here it won't budge all right it is
we got to go up I think let's find this
videotape
thingy shouldn't this be able to play it
I don't know I I don't even know anymore
okay since we can't go there I guess
it's got to go here whatever who knows I
know I don't know
Senoritas anyone want to [__] with
me no maybe in here is there a video
tape here let share no okay
fine all right I guess we got to go
here I'm hoping this is correct I don't
even know anymore
why do I need to play a video tape it
makes no sense but let's do it anyway I
love vide tapes my mom used to play them
all the time
okay I guess here cuz I have no [__]
clue there are no monsters so they I
don't think this is
correct hey lovely what back off Ruben's
mom [__] up [__] up I'm playing a vide
tape
here you inserted the video Tap
Play
Play There we go hey that's solid
what what are you doing Mr Shar what are
you doing what are you I knew he was M
what the
hell all right what's he doing he
punched him why would he do that oh no
he's going to cut off his penis oh no
you don't cut off a man's P oh it's
head damn girl
why would he film man that's is
disturbing W
two 2739 and he rot it on his
body
re I know I forgot 2739
2739 escape the apartments with the
elevators Escape I don't like escaping
all right let's find the elevator I
think it's over here here
2799 ah [__] where is the
elevator H it's in the other
hallway I think at
least I got I I keep trying to remember
the
code I remember now oh sweet baby Jesus
thank
you why should I escape with the
elevator there's a keypad all right 2739
please be right yes like a boss all
right Let's Escape this [__] I unlocked
it like a b word I think at least it
could be a b
word oh snap I don't touch this why does
it go down it should
go I hate this old elevators they creep
me
[Music]
out okay so now I escaped
what oh come
on okay as long as those [__] babies
whatever just don't [__] show up oh
more ammo
sweet oh this is
hello oh those [__]
babies I hate them what is this all
right let's
just go down more ammo this is not good
that means it's going to be a fight with
a lot of people a lot of people I want
oh no I don't know sen ever I don't like
this I don't like this may Lord have
mercy on my penis okay let's keep going
down I suppose [__] it goes down a lot
are we playing SCP now is this the new
SCP
game all right creepy Corridor I fought
many of these
before we can do it
again hello
what is this yes yes Save back a
b
hello this St does not look good I don't
want to know what's on the other side
I'm going to end it here anyway like and
fav if you enjoyed subscribe to become a
bro today and I'll see you in next
[Music]
episode I can't do it that
long
a oh my God how do you do it for that